can you recall a story from when you
were in the cubicle life
where you just that was like the final
straw
and and it lit a fire under you yes
yes um so i
i was approached by my manager's
boss he was like the director of the
department and um
you know he said hey i i talked to
so-and-so and they said
you know that you do a lot of this video
stuff and you've done some internal
videos for
you know one of our groups and we have a
very big project it's like this yearly
project
and um we wanted to know if you want to
project manage and do the whole thing
and you know put it all together
and this is going to be for all the vps
and for you know the ceo of the company
and it's like
you know and it was a big deal and they
were gonna have this whole thing
down at disney and you know there was a
lot of pressure
and i was like you know okay wait so
what do you want
and he wanted something very creative
and i said okay
so i went home and i wrote a script
you know i storyboarded and i you know
did everything that i you know had
already learned how to do
and i came in and i i said okay um
so here's the concept i've come up with
and let me know what you think
and i gave him you know this folder and
he's like wait what is all this
i said well okay so first here's the
script and he's looking at it he's like
you this is a and it was like you know
a real script because i use final draft
so
i know how to write screenplays and he
didn't realize that i had
those abilities because it's not
anything i did for them um
you know and and he was just like when
did when did you have time to do all
this and then he saw all my storyboards
you know hand
know exactly how everything was gonna be
framed out and he was like you know
extremely impressed and he was just like
okay what do you need
you know next thing you know he was
contacting their internal media
department
to get me a couple cameras and get me
other people to work with
and you know he's like i love this i
can't wait to see how this is gonna
turn out and um how it turned out is
that
the the vp of the company um
saw it and was blown away and gave me
a thousand dollar on the spot bonus
and like you know it was so that was a
huge deal
um because she had never given anybody
uh apparently a bonus like this and so
it was one thing
to have the fact that you know this this
video
that i created that it was being shown
on all these big screens at disney
for the entire company it was another
thing for her literally in front of
everybody after everything
to bring me up and and say you know
that i really went above and beyond you
know what anybody would have expected
and just kind of set a bar for what
all their you know internal
communication needs to be and she gave
me a thousand dollar
bonus and so that was pretty amazing so
and i think at that moment it occurred
to me
why am i not you know why am i not doing
this
professionally for myself why you know
i mean it's great to have these
opportunities come up every
so often you know in a company that
you're working for but
why isn't this when this was the whole
reason i came to la
you know the whole reason i wanted to be
in la was to pursue a career
in film you know and so why am i not
doing it you know
you